I've never seen a movie like this
we're revving to give you everything we
got
we got something special so let's
celebrate that it's the end of the road
so we're going back to the roots of Fast
and Furious
then I go what kind of trouble can we
get into this time everything is bigger
better and hits you like a right hand of
the jaw
it is True Entertainment on a massive
canvas you're about to learn all about
fear with a new villain with new Stakes
real steaks I hadn't played a villain in
probably 10 years all right dorks what
are we blowing up I wanted to bring
something to the lineage that hadn't
been done yet he just comes in guns
blazing you guys are going to hell
Dante is really one angry guy but really
well dressed to face off against Dom and
his family you had to be a certain
psychotic he's coming for you with
everything
there's something coming and Dom knows
it I can't think of a better time for
him to be at a Crossroads never accept
that
three years old we're all feeling unsure
at the moment even down
this is Sarah we haven't been as
successful as we're used to seeing this
team be and that's kind of scary
this sets the stage for something larger
so it's unfamiliar territory that's the
problem with having such a big family
how do you choose the ones you save
I really am looking forward to the
toretos being back together again we're
firing on all cylinders
is it exciting yes
he's trying to tear us apart is it
nerve-wracking hell yeah this is the
magic of fast Let's Race it's showtime
we go it's the beginning of the end it's
the sum of everything we've loved in the
Fast and Furious Universe here they come
it's exciting to be a piece in the
puzzle of something that's so very
important pop culture I do suggest for
the audience out there to prep it's a
big one for a saga to be complete it
must have an end it's bittersweet but
dare I say more meaningful